[Applaudissements]
garcia l'on commence avec le champion du
monde des marseillais greg bien entendu
hier vous le savez grec c'est un grand
romantique on vous la présenter résultat
ils tombent amoureux
tous les jours hier il expliqué à sa
nouvelle copine mélanie les yeux dans
les yeux qu après une ultime discussion
avec son ex mari va c'était terminé
on va revoir quoi vous nous avez réclamé
regarde moi j'ai besoin d'un bon oeil
il faut que j'arrive à passer à autre
chose je vais y arriver je le sais là ce
soir avant une ultime discussion
concours avec elle et après c'est fini
je m'en fous tout le monde qu'on est des
êtres humains
j'ai juste une manette
et après c'est fini bon alors ça c'est
clair ça c'était hier et ben helli vie
ta ble ment greg est re re re tomber
amoureux de maeva juste avant bien
entendu de re re re re re tomber
amoureux de mme elhady donc grecque en
fait c'est un jour une meuf voilà c'est
la dernière cas par l'équipe le plus
regardé
[Musique]
mais mes sentiments cachés bois s'est
pas dit les murs bête je ne peux pas
vous ferez pouvoir est passé toute ma
vie j'ai moi je m'en fous j'ai pas peur
de le dire en fait j'ai pas peur d'en du
terrain des sentiments haut et fort je
ferai tout pour elle ou gelé dans la
peau gelés dans la peau je joue c'est
incompréhensible en fait même moi je
comprends pas même moi même moi je
comprends pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui vraiment sai fini de tourner la page
maintenant il faut que j'aille de
l'avant et je pense que tu tu pourrais
être la personne ses poulains qui pourra
me faire avancer attendre c'est au moins
la dixième fois qu'ils me le dit
[Musique]
c'est juste que j'ai un coeur et que je
réfléchis avec mon coeur tout simplement
[Applaudissements]
alors le problème de greg c'est qu'à
force de chine et toutes les meufs en
même temps forcément un moment plus
aucune meuf de la villa ne veut lui
parler
c'est un problème voilà assez août et
sur un dos tous les dostie les deux
soirs troodos tulle dos et comme
personne ne veut lui parler et qu'il a
besoin de ce livre est la seule personne
qui écoute encore greg passé la pelouse
et le soir l'après midi je mange et
baise moi la classe alors héros des jeux
par l'asa vas-y vas-y je parle à l'air
ballon j'en peux plus j'ai une fille
aussi j'aime alors que j'ai je me prends
pour une bunny et j'ai notre cas où la
ddt qui ne fait pas c'est vraiment pour
l'homme pour le mec méchant alors pas du
tout justement j'ai été clair avec elle
je fais quoi c'est pas moi
c'est pas moi ne prend la tête c'est pas
moi c'est pas greg hill avec pagaille et
j'embrasse pour bagarre ils sont bloqués
franchement j'ai des doutes c'est que
l'équipe doit vraiment alors greg il ya
un autre problème quand il n'est pas un
mort de faim avec les meufs
ben il est mort de faim tout court les
équipes halte bouffe tout le temps même
quand ça n'a rien à voir la semaine
dernière pendant une embrouille il nous
avait pondu la recette du couscous voilà
il en pleine brouille et cette semaine
et ben c'est celle du kebab marseillais
regarder j'en suis en fait elle me prend
pour un jambon beurre c'est le pompon
sur la figue de prendre vraiment pour un
kebab les sambas clip
demain dit je me surprends prigent
moment comme il nous l'est pour être
complet
[Musique]
tu as aidé pour les marseillais et j'ai
un petit bonus les chéris un petit bonus
vous le savez dès que j'ai besoin de me
détendre je regarde la chaîne métro tv
alors mais doté dé ckoi géraldine de
musique qu'ils diffusent en continu des
concerts de musique classique et cette
nuit par exemple j'ai regardé la suite
numéro 1 en mi bémol de gustav holst
alors c'était sublime à voir et entendre
je me suis fait un groupe qui est
surtout le percussionniste qui s'est un
peu emballé avec son tambour
regardez bien le gars et les partir on
rit mais c'est rien de bien méchant j'ai
eu toutes les personnes au téléphone
salut tout le monde
[Musique]
ouais
on voit qu'il est plus plus en plus
veinards il ya mon ami sans briller que
sa meuf sais pas
/
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
jordi leur mère doit être castré on a vu